my name is chip east with the alabama
cooperative extension system
and today i'll be talking to you about
grafting tomatoes
why graft tomatoes there are several
reasons to graft tomatoes but my number
one reason
is to increase the resistance to soil
borne diseases
for example grafting a non-disease
heirloom onto a hybrid root stock
would be an excellent way to increase
disease resistance
without grafting crop rotation and
choosing a disease-resistant cultivar
could help as well you need to select
your root stock seed based on potential
problems
such as nematodes and fusion wilt
those could be avoided from grafting but
other diseases such as early blight and
bacterial spot
will not you need to select heirloom
varieties based on your market factors
if your heirloom varieties do not make
more money
it may be better to grow a disease
resistant hybrid instead
and grafting requires a lot of
additional time
and you need to take that into
consideration and plan for that
you should construct a healing chamber
before the grafting process begins
this chamber should hold the humidity at
80 to 95 percent
the temperature should be between 70 and
80 degrees fahrenheit
we should exclude light and we can set
this up in advance
before the grafting process begins
the black plastic over this chamber will
exclude light in this example
and it's hard to see but there's water
standing in the bottom of this there's
plastic with water in it to keep the
humidity high
the hard part of this is keeping the
temperature between 70 and 80 degrees
sanitation is very important when
grafting
we're grafting to hopefully avoid
diseases so we don't want to spread
diseases
while we're doing this process a razor
blade has
been a good thing to make the cuts with
the only special equipment other than
the
healing chamber is these and you can get
silicone grafting clips but there are
other grafting clips available the
pictures i'm going to show are these
silicone grafting clips
and they come in different sizes
depending on the plant material
which one you would use what time of day
is best for this type
grafting is whenever the water stress is
lowest maybe early in the morning
or late in the evening inside
under a shade maybe out of the wind all
those are good
examples of places to be when grafting
tomatoes
the sign or the desirable temela
is cut at a 45 degree angle the root
stock is cut at a 45
degree angle placed together and held
with a grafting clip
this is just an example we have it
laying down normally the
root stock would just remain in the pot
or cell pack and we would hold our
razor blade at an angle to make the cut
try to do a 45 degree angle as possible
but the stem diameter is the most
important thing
the root stock and the sign need to have
the same
size stem you would think we could plant
the seeds at the same time
and they would always be the same size
stem but sometimes
this root stock might grow faster
so we might have to plant one of the
varieties a week or two early
than the other
here you can see an example of the sign
held in place to the root stock with the
use of that silicone grafton clip and
you can see that
a 45 degree angle or as close to it as
possible
the newly grafted plants will go
directly into the healing chamber
as soon as possible for two to four days
exclude light and give them high
humidity if you have to water water
under the bottom
do not wet them on top they look pretty
stressed
but after a couple of days they start
looking a lot better
after two or three days those grafted
plants should start looking a lot better
then we start introducing them to a
little more light we do this by opening
up that
healing chamber that would lower the
humidity and give them a little light
and we just open a little more each day
for several days
don't allow the plants to become
stressed but we do want to start
preparing them to go into the field
we can give them more light but don't
put them in the full sun for several
days
after about two weeks the plants would
be ready to go into the field
and do not bury the graft union when you
plant them
if you bury the graft union that plant
can
root out above the graft and
become infected by these soil borne
diseases
one potential problem is the plant
sucker in below the graft union
remove those suckers from below the
graft union as soon as you find them
if you have any questions about grafton
grafton tomato plants you can contact
your local extension office
or you can call me direct
you